next to face my video evidence is a zoo
from London in the North African heat
head chef Chris produced some wonderful
authentic Algerian food delicious merci
but my coach trip exposed some
weaknesses front-of-house that's twice
I've sent an undercover critic Simon
Davis to see if Chris assigned out his
front-of-house problems and is still
sending out perfectly cooked food that's
the chicken man damn disappointing
I've chicken slightly overcooked dry
simple charming and delicious but they
have to be consistent finally it's the
milestone from Sheffield run by four
ambitious young men this restaurant is
reinventing classic British food but
they made errors for my last they could
done and I paid a visit
would you either no so why should I use
it
to progress in this competition I need
to know the milestone team are learning
from their mistakes
they start with a little freebie
homemade mousse and cumin flatbread
next up its place Phyllis serve with a
lemon pith puree places are delicate
fresh and it needs help acidic certainly
but not maybe lemon pit slightly bitter
foxi my one problem with milestone is
their lack of experience can they get
better I'm a month seven